saying goodbyes  saying hello  you think your wife can hear you no  no a white ball  Maybe I'm Wrong  maybe not goodbye to you my trusted  friend  a new day is Dawning  new ideas no wounds  New Management we've  [Music]  been who is this  challenging to single combat with a  loose it's a way out  I don't sit at the table your family  does please pray for me  [Music]  man has to look his best when it's time  to get married  or buried  I'm going to need a gun goodbye my  friend  [Music]  if you win  the table will honor its word  you'll have your freedom  that's the old laws only one can survive  here to meet at sunrise  for results and execution  Last Words Winston just happened  [Music]  I want you to find your peace but the  good death only comes after a good life  you and I left a good life behind a long  time ago my friend  [Music]